[Music]
in for me homeless news oh yeah why
can't they be horny yeah I saw a video
of two homeless people [ __ ] on a
random mattress on the side of the road
that a blanket over them though that's
weird that you would support them the
funny thing is there's that mattress on
the side of the road and they're like
let's do it
like we're the rude ones look you
Lincoln is the walls yeah it's weird the
dude walked up and started recording
like in your weird guy's a pervert well
I don't know let's see how you guys feel
about this one though submitted by
karate versus kung fu costume which ones
what it there are different places of
origins Kung Fu is Chinese yeah karate
is doubleness kungfu sucks a man has
been accused of sexually assaulting a
dying beaver what members how to blame
the beaver back to life I don't know how
people look at animals and think yeah I
saw a [ __ ] photo once a guy [ __ ]
an old rotting cats cat corpse maybe
they're just Ronnie just thinking about
soft something soft to put their digging
we saw the video of the guy [ __ ] the
muffler but why can't you just buy like
a jar of that like marshmallow fluff
like that soft
that's pillowy back in the day during
the ale all days like 56k days there was
his viral video going around let's get
the [ __ ] burp out oh wait I lost it
whoa buddy but it was a girl that was
getting boned by I think a German
Shepherd a golden retriever and I got
turned on that's also like 13 or 14 so I
think any porn I want to turn me on that
why do you see this [ __ ] well you put me
on Mary
I saw I saw this portal cuz I married
you you [ __ ] weirdo voluntarily
it's still processing in my brand you
saw and I never surfing these I never
searched for it it's not that weird yeah
I never searched for that it's weird you
got turned down by a girl getting
photogenic Oh porn it's like an octopus
[ __ ] a girl guys get turned on by
that - is that real they're cartoon it's
car - but it's the same thing
not really no cos porn guys don't see it
as real it's just like a sex object like
it's a different fantasy world it's like
if you don't know you get turned on you
know like if you don't know but you
don't understand you know like something
so out of the ordinary that you kind of
cuz I saw one portal world you just like
like kind of like I'm not like I've
always had dogs so then that's not
something that's so for in that I'd be
like oh yeah that's hot you don't even
like it's not that foreign I saw this
one worse this girl is taking care of
her [ __ ] and then the guy comes in and
I was like oh yeah they're gonna [ __ ]
and then she grabs the horse's dick and
start sucking it and I was like that's
[ __ ] hot okay but I was always
confused though I was like those like I
was like I thought the guy was gonna do
it with her and but she grabbed a dick
they all they did it with her he was
sucking the horses no she spun a sucking
the horses dick why do they have to
bring head of yours just out of your
mouth a huge or some [ __ ]
yes [ __ ] its massive it's like it's
like trying to suck a firehose bug so
like she was like yeah she's just had
all of I was like this is [ __ ]
disgusting yeah and I was like a pawn I
was like oh
I was like that's wrong but I can't kick
I can't cook away yeah that's why cuz
you said it turned me on you did honest
there's videos I get watch it again
there was I disassociate myself with
that statement there's some videos like
this middle-aged white dude that was
like getting banged by a horse
oh yeah he's dead bro and then
afterwards he's like oh my God thank you
so much like he horse he paid someone to
let the horse [ __ ] he died after from
internal organ
yeah that's a very strange place it's
weird
dead like dying Anna will be like I'm
gonna [ __ ] that you know leave all
homeless poor person we kind of
sometimes associate with like will the
dead I'm in the dying beaver could I
talk dirty to him like you ain't gonna
get or you know he's so high like Beaver
[ __ ] beaver what are you doing here you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah because he's so hot
oh my god listen a with meth no but but
but a lot of people are meth do
hallucinate cuz they don't sleep yeah
this day not the man that makes you
hallucinate it's being up for three days
alright well so this took place in
Washington and this woman her name's
Whitney she she saw that this beaver boy
she fights a girl no she thought happen
so she stumbles upon okay so she
actually she ran over this beaver
he's a funny [ __ ] I gotta get up okay
so she [ __ ] it runs over the beaver
right she goes oh no she gets out of
their car and a homeless man runs up
what the words say is that she stumbled
upon this beaver while driving that
doesn't mean that's no but that was the
same shitty run the zero like the
homeless guy was in the bushes waiting
for roadkill beaver was injured saw this
beaver oh she's driving right so this is
whitney by the way if you want to put a
face to her but wait named dave her eyes
are crazy yeah she looks like she could
be like elven she is cute and the hair
is crazy together anyway so she sees
this injured beaver she rushes home to
get a box to put the beaver into gross
waiting veterinary but then when she
came back she saw that this man was
crouching near and this beaver and she
consented to it so she was like oh
that's so nice he's helping this beaver
to but then the closer she got she
realized that his pants were unzipped
and may he was actually [ __ ] this
behold damn where did he put it in the
beaver [ __ ] in the beaver please God
[ __ ] or bottles but isn't it thank
you but like Jesus from that like oh
yeah dude so this is a photo receiver oh
she should have got a photo of him
[ __ ] the beaver ah not the dead vemma
beaver I mean I don't know this
when I got weight what the hell it does
not look [ __ ] but you know a lot of
people they want to go out having sex so
at least the beaver went out might be
one of the best ways because people know
that beavers dead though right yeah good
thing that it was dead or else it would
have been a rape I kind of want to were
they like in the woods in Washington I
don't know because I've just pictured
this [ __ ] being like all foresty and
then all of a sudden there's a crack hit
in the middle of the forest
[ __ ] jumps out of nowhere to animals
in roadkill I just pictured a crack head
with a [ __ ] peanut butter and
mushroom sandwich and he's chomping on
that [ __ ] high maybe he was
there for bad intentions hmm right like
what if he was just on a mission to [ __ ]
that it apart Columbia oh he was been
what he's been waiting for okay
and everything just failed and then a
beaver showed up well thank goodness cuz
maybe he would have raped somebody yeah
he [ __ ] the beaver instead that's true
let's hope that's the Beavers like last
good deal with a hero oh that's
something like they do because they're
bored all day so they're if they're not
smoking crack or doing like meth or some
[ __ ] then then they're like they got to
find other hobbies and then they're like
maybe among their bum friends don't like
have you ever [ __ ] roadkill you're
like well I swear it's almost yeah that
sounds real you know what happens on
meth you know and then because I mean
they got like 12 other hours that
they're not doing [ __ ] you know if
they're not panhandling or eating food
what would you do if you saw that beaver
getting [ __ ] I would record oh la la
would you like stop the person or just
like the beaver already dead well that's
the thing like
he was injured by the time she left so
that's why she was gonna try to get help
but that get to death
that's like we don't know if it died and
then he [ __ ] it or he [ __ ] it to
death I would be like hey but what if he
looks at you and goes oh no what do you
do I don't know I don't know if people
would look at me like that and they hear
it he has his dick [ __ ] a beaver like
[ __ ] you cuz that's the kind of guy that
will bite me oh you don't know what it
is who he's [ __ ] what it's a bunch of
his aids teeth yep he's the kind of guy
that will finger his butthole to try to
get himself the diarrhea so you could
shoot it at you
I don't really think about it like that
I just think in the moment and then I'll
try to figure it out as it happens I try
not to fight homeless people that's all
I'm saying that's why in New York City
I'm sorry I I have to tell my truth okay
so what happened was I went there with
my fiance he was invited to some like
fancy work of it and I was like the
lowest of the low for me I was there for
a free work trip but I wasn't going
because the seats were like $15,000 a
seat so I was like okay you know what
I'm gonna pay out on some hello guys go
back to the hotel
find my wallet open you went she was
like it was like shift change so all the
stuff is changing I was in the front of
the line and I got two of them so it's
$14 remember this exactly and I gave
them a ten and a five and they gave me a
dollar back and I didn't realize the
entire time there's a homeless person
standing next to me so I closed the
while I got my food and he goes man do
you have any change and I said sorry I
don't have any like big wine like I said
isn't it like Todd my son and you know
the customers anybody else help you know
nobody helped me they were just like oh
my god he just spit if that person spit
on me oh hell no and I was like well
what do you want me to do
a new drunken spat on by a [ __ ]
homeless guy yeah oh yeah homeless guy
didn't like run away like he was still
like getting rowdy with me response oh
yeah and I was like crying and like New
Yorkers come on help a [ __ ] out
Oh like nobody yeah probably like oh
that's [ __ ] scary Larry over there
scary Larry will bite you I tried
[ __ ] confronting him before oh I see
you met Smitty Steve okay I saw you with
that dollar you guys are like you kind
of deserved it everybody knows what spit
ecv point at the sign like the oh she's
at that point you don't say anything you
just go violin no like what would you
say you saw you have cash and you get
the cutest spicy
this is my money I work hard and he
looked a little crazy
I'll just get a napkin and I'll put the
spit away and I'll walk away yeah
because it just depends and I showered
with all the clothes on like really
chaotic crying yeah scared like what if
I have my new cut somewhere nothing else
we want aids but like aids I sell I
treat it like they do I do it everyone
like yeah they spit on me I really
that's carpet in the hospital that's
what you're supposed to do you're
supposed to treat everything as if
everything has a it's called the AIDS
mentality no there is a term afro and
it's called ate mind maybe a
but Whitney ended up posting she's like
he's deceased
I caught a homeless man having sex with
the beaver I'm traumatized yeah did I'd
be Thompson if I saw any dude banging an
animal especially half dead one though
ooh
no I got it wrong and Joe no you got it
wrong if the person knows the animal
bang and the person is what I got turned
on by now yeah how does I'm banging it
the [ __ ] wrong way dude there's a
difference
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]